foreign
so I came across the story from the New
York Post
and
um do you want to read this you want to
read here you want to read the title
Marsh
200 titles uh I divorced my dying
husband he wallowed in self-pity and
killed my vibe
bro this at this point
[Laughter]
I'm starting to get to this point where
this feels
like I don't know
like it almost just feels like a psyop
this can't be real well it's real
because every week now there's a story
like this
until death it was part a woman has
opened up about why she diverse divorced
her dying husband saying his five-year
cancer battle took a toll on their
marriage and he wallowed in self-pity
Jana Frye was dying
what the [__] I think we can all agree
when somebody's dying right you're
allowed to have self-pity you're allowed
hey you're allowed to also pity right
and B we're all supposed to suffer
through your shitty personality because
you're dying and it's it's temporary for
us
he's dying you know what I mean you
still got to go visit your grandpa Jana
fry 40. you just don't you just don't
make me come anymore I'm coughing up
blood I have my hair's falling out yeah
my dick doesn't get hard because I just
went in for three different rounds of
chemo I was on the phone with Armando
yesterday my grandfather for 20 minutes
trying to explain him I put his wall set
the alarm on his new smartphone and it
was so frustrating it's the best I stay
calm you stay calm as you can because
obviously but he's like still angry
stubborn because he's [__] He's
related to me by the way if you don't
know how he is he's angry stubborn and
he's skinny man like ow please please
listen to me there's an app called clock
you go to the app called clock what he
was doing was his old phone let him
search for apps you just type the app he
was going to the Google thing and typing
clock
he was getting pictures of like people
tell people selling clocks
late late husband when she was 22 years
old and dreamed of starting a family
with him but the bride's dream that
piece of [__] that selfish [__] had
to go ahead and get sick you don't
really she wasn't into it anyway you
could tell her she was 22 when he was 37
when they got married yeah she was she
was looking forward to his dying but the
bride streamer soon dashed when her
husband then 37 diagnosed with
testicular the bride's dreams were Dash
yeah it was her dream see you know what
I mean I hate when that happens I hate
when you know I got my whole life
planned out I'm so excited about the
future and then my wife goes and gets
cancer like what a [__] I made a lot of
plans for us sweetheart and now you're
out here doing this
but yeah but the bride streamer okay we
couldn't really uh think about our
future for I told women oh my God women
how can you plant for your future as a
newly married couple when you're
struggling with someone with something
like cancer
people react in one of two ways to
critical illness I've seen over the
years she continued the first type was
how my husband unfortunately was the
people who drown in self-pity the second
type are people who who are instead
concerned with everyone around them so
she wasn't getting enough attention from
him because he was sad he was dying
a woman uh a woman she's got it out he
had he had cancer in his balls that
would make like like you I could get
cancer in my leg in my [__] like
liver like wherever your balls man
that's your balls dude it's your balls
dude bro uh fry who was living in New
York City with her husband said no one
was worried about how she was doing
during the difficult time I'm gonna read
that again
my article is that when she literally
starts with killing me but her dreams
were dashed when he got sick they never
asked do you need any support are you
part of counseling oh my God honey
you're not hot enough by the way to act
like this no oh my God this woman how
old is she there 22.
oh she looks 40. Fry's husband continued
treatment for his cancer but the disease
only worsened I was hoping the best with
my ex-husband's cancer but then years
went by and I started to lose hope
it was five years with all the
treatments and it started to change the
Dynamics within our relationships
uh it wasn't until the fifth year that I
started to think about leaving but I
felt like I couldn't say anything when
someone is dying next to you you feel
like you can't talk about your own
well-being because you're compared to
the suffering listen to this listen to
this woman
fry said she was more I I'm you know man
I'm struggling with this one I mean I I
you know oh I know wow fry says she was
motivated to finally leave her sickly
spouse after a friend took their uh
their own life
uh I was hoping for the uh I was it was
it my fear it was it was my first
funeral and it was very shocking for I
explained over Pal's unexpected suicide
in my mind at a time suicide became an
option even though I had never
considered it before I was such a bad
taste it was very clear to me that if I
didn't save myself I was probably going
to die she dramatically added
I love this woman she's the best
fried lovely woman fry subsequently
filed for divorce from her husband
leaving him stunned his main focus was
more and more about him she stated
because he's cancer at the beginning of
the treatment he was still checking on
me but he felt even more pity for
himself this is her look I I huh she's a
life coach look she's a life coach now
guys you wonder why women are [__] up
she's a life coach now
I can't even uh I can't even say that he
was hugely supportive she further
admitted but that was even harder was a
reaction to society which I didn't
expect fry says people sent her horrible
messages you deserve whatever messages
you're saying you deserve worse and that
her husband's family was disappointed
people were in pain and they wanted to
blame someone
they know they're blaming you for
leaving him not for the cancer
fry says that she and her husband
subsequently stopped speaking he ended
up remarrying before he passed away two
years later good for him yeah he
remarried passed away two years later
good for him uh to pull that off huh is
is I mean amazing so he couldn't have
been that self-pitying he was able to
get another chick while he still I Can't
This Woman's also lying too you know
she's an insufferable [__] I actually
found out on Facebook that he passed
away there was a picture of him from a
common friend and it said rest in peace
my first reaction is you must be joking
someone would have called me and told me
but why would somebody wow
this is a very revealing little thing so
everyone hates this woman everything in
their circles hates this woman yeah if
nobody called them nobody called her and
told her because nobody's taught listen
and you know what there's people that
probably agree with her there's women
that probably agree with her uh my first
reaction was you must be joking somebody
would have called me and told me but no
one did she mournfully added fry has
since moved to Singapore I would move
there too if I were you and works as a
life coach she's also remarried she says
she has no regrets about leaving her
dying husband but admit she spent years
in therapy trying to work through
complicated emotions this hurt her more
than anybody else I'm a man guilt it's
called guilt
uh I feel we yeah wait wait you got you
guys have feelings uh women feel guilt
they just don't understand it as an
abstract yeah women feel guilt but they
react with resentment because they
should never feel bad ever and only feel
good it's kind of the way uh it's the
same way like um like Italian guys get
when they feel any kind of emotion yeah
like whenever they feel like emotional
about something and they want to cry
instead they're like no I gotta [__]
hit somebody yeah so I gotta work
through my emotions that's that's why
Irish people don't cry they just punch
their wives yeah it's true uh I feel we
especially women are just usually
brought up in this mentality to serve
others but when you go against it you
learn a lot about resilience and
self-awareness oh no yeah but when John
Edwards not not the [__] not the
Kearney but the well they're both
carnies but the senator remember when he
[__] cheated on his wife cancer
everyone [__] what an I cannot
believe him I had to have years of
therapy to learn that I'm not a horrible
person for making that decision that I
did no no no no no no if you had to go
to therapy for not feeling like a
horrible person then you should feel
like a horrible person if you need
somebody to tell you every day that
you're not hard somebody you're paying
money to you're paying somebody money to
tell you you're not horrible that's what
therapy is
that's what it is
therapy is confirming it's just
confirmation bias it's you're giving
them money and of course you're going to
say you're not a terrible person because
they want you to go back that way you
feel good about yourself